let's talk about this and then we'll get
into polls we have the story from the
new york post do you want to read the
headline
joe biden reportedly exports 5 million
oil barrels despite u.s grants prices
how from our strategic oil reserve
i i i thripped my mouth a little bit
when i saw this story i couldn't believe
it i couldn't believe
that they would be so stupid or just so
evil
gas prices are through the roof they're
at record highs it's like i think 480
according to aaa five it hit five you
know a month ago people are struggling
they're dipping into their savings
they're running out of money
peop the supply chain is is crippled and
joe biden says yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna
pull 20 million barrels for the
strategic reserve to help make lower
prices you know what i'm saying and then
we find out now he exported to europe
and asia so let me just simplify this
for you at a time when we don't have
enough and the prices are through the
roof biden gave some away
for what reason i i i don't know how you
look at a story like this and think that
the democrats could win anything
maybe he exported it at a profit
spiking the market somewhere else
there's one argument that but he's
trying to
spike the the price of gas by selling
below market losing money intentionally
to force everyone else to compete with
the low price but he doesn't have enough
oil to do that that's what i was going
to say it's not enough to drive
i think it has more to do with ukraine
oh god no yeah i think it's it's they
want fuel for the war
and so i think that's what they're doing
you're wondering
in the ukraine yo joe might be could you
did it
was engaged in illicit deals with
ukraine and now he's cutting checks by a
billion if he sends it to germany and
then germany sends theirs to ukraine we
essentially sent it to ukraine
it's called laundering
you also have uh
putin
the movements from the russia russian
army we were all told he was going to go
into kiev but it was a failure so we had
to pull back if you look at where he is
i mean he's right over the shelter pods
so
i mean this
you know i don't know how you can look
at the russian military's position and
and conclude anything other than the
western media was lying to us and
absolutely putin absolutely had a plan
and insane propaganda all these videos
coming out of ukrainian soldiers with
cigars being like i just killed a bunch
of russians
i like ukraine i have friends there
amazing country really enjoyed my time
there i'm sad to see what's happening
but i am sick of the lies and the
manipulation i think there's two things
one i think it is bad that putin invaded
i think he was losing the soft power
conflict so he wanted he he wants to
maintain control of crimea for the warm
water port he wants the eastern regions
for a lot of reasons there's politics
there's ideology there's partisanship
all that stuff
however
i think joe biden in a much bigger way
is beholden to ukraine for the illicit
deals that he was doing and that
explains it look people are like why
didn't vladimir putin invade when donald
trump was president
good question i think putin did fear
donald trump a little bit why is all
this going down now under joe biden
because i think joe biden was cutting
back room deals i'm sorry i'm sorry i
gotta pause i don't think i know it
because there's a video of joe biden
saying i said you're not getting the
money unless you fire the prosecutor
just so happens that prosecutor was
investigating the company where joe
biden's son was on the board so i'm not
saying that's why he fired the guy i'm
not going that far i'm saying
wouldn't any prosecutor just show that
to a jury and be like hey how about that
so now joe biden is cutting our taxpayer
dollars or i should say federal reserve
money by the billions what are that 70
billion dollars and then he's like we're
going to spend hundreds of millions of
more weapons and fuel now going to
europe i think they got him by the balls
i think joe biden was cutting dirty
deals for his son and now he has no
choice but to but to force us to be
involved and i don't think it's just joe
biden i think it's the bureaucratic
state they've invested too much in this
and they won't back down so the
democrats are all on board and then the
low information voters who are too
stupid to realize what's going on who
couldn't tell you where cutter was let
alone the cutter turkey pipeline are
sitting there going like yank yo biden
you're a hero it's lava ukrainia which
is why it was such a scandal the media
held all of this from the american
people and electorate to begin with
because
this is why you care whether your
president is doing deals like this if if
obama had appointed him as the front man
for us ukraine relations and he used
that position to enrich his family to
enrich himself
you don't put people who are potentially
i don't want to use the
rachel maddow word but they can they can
they got you by the short and curlies
and you have no choice i mean the poll
has been going back to the polling
americans never wanted to do this they
never wanted to send lethal aid at one
point we barely had them teetering in
favor of sending humanitarian aid which
is just you know very ethical term you
know they just view it as money
but when you got to lethal force or
anything else
they were out they never and he just
ignored that so yeah have you ever seen
an unpopular president
ignore the will of the people and do
what joe biden does in these cases i
would argue no and you never see a
congressional democratic leadership any
majority who has an unpopular president
just ignore the unpopularity of these
moves and just full steam ahead
as if there's no political repercussions
they just don't care it looks like
something else it's different that's not
how it works you know
presidents with 37 approval ratings
don't have political crowd this is this
is the perfect example of the ship hit
the iceberg and the elites are stealing
as much fine china and silverware as
they can before running to the lifeboats
and everyone's going what what what are
you doing and they're like slavo
ukrainian and you're like yeah okay and
then they jump on the lifeboats and then
when we fix the boat they'll be like oh
oh i found all this silverware that
someone was trying to steal crazy that's
great let me back into my room
tomorrow i i think that's one way to put
it i wouldn't go so far as to say the
ship sinks and we're all just adrift and
they're riding away on the lifeboats
waving the silverware at us i think
what's likely to happen is that
the ship sinks partially it's crippled
we're all still on it life sucks a bit
and then we see them off in the distance
parting cheering with china pouring the
champagne and being like
there you go
and then human ingenuity kicks in and
we're like well
we evolved because we have to let's fix
this boat question is what do we do we
hunt them down do we do we sail after
these criminals and punish them or do we
just live on with our daily lives and
make life better
i like your outcome better all right i
do it's more optimistic you know but it
is true um i think we'll be okay yeah i
think there's a way of writing itself
tim but i think bad things are ahead i
think i think you look at stories like
this and i'm just surprised they would
even dare admit it yeah
you know just
joe biden is effectively looking you in
the eyes american people and saying hey
man five bucks a gallon so what i gave
your strategic oil reserves away
the oil that we have saved for a rainy
day not for high prices but for when
we're at war or there's a major shortage
he just given it away oh maybe he
considers us at war maybe that's what
this is i wonder who descendants is true
who did he send it to
it was exported to europe and asia it
was sold it was transported companies
were involved look i think the official
explanation is that they were hoping to
shock the market into lower prices it's
just massively stupid way too little i
don't i don't care if that was the case
that's not what strategic oil reserves
are for exactly
this is this reeks of joe biden is
dragging the united states into a
conflict with russia
nato is involved us intelligence is
aiding ukrainians and they're just
pretending like they didn't unilaterally
unilaterally declare war yeah that's
what they do when that his advisor came
out like three or four days ago or last
week i think and said you know this is
all for he didn't use liberal economic
order he used the do you remember the
liberal world liberal world order also
known as the liberal economic order
us-led global rules-based economy
there's all these names for it but it
was pretty clear that that's why we're
suffering right now but then he has the
audacity today to go out
and make the remarks that he makes and
he chuckles about
i call it putin inflation as if anyone
believes that nobody believes that dude
he did a talk where he was like it's
russia russia russia russia like a brady
bunch brady bunch yep marsha marsha they
they i think at this point he knows he's
done
and and they i i think the democrats
were like look we're gonna run biden
against trump we're gonna get obama
nostalgia
then we put all of our sins upon him and
sacrifice this kid yeah i think all of
the really awful things they wanted to
do they put on buy-in so that they get
them out and then they can be like oh
geez oh you know we'll come and fix it
i don't see how uh
any democrat could win like 24 and 24.
we've pulled them all save a miracle had
their problem because i i think you're
right about that they were going to just
sacrifice him and you know put kamala
right in there uh because these people
really believe she was likable or would
be like i kid you not that's the
craziest thing the bubble these people
live in they really thought she was
going to be like the second murder talk
she basically never got to iowa yet
somehow the general electorate is going
to fall in love with her so now they're
in this position we've pulled them all
kamala pete buddha judge hillary i last
month i had to bring back hillary
clinton no i don't because but nobody's
viable trump is killing them all yeah
you know what that's the next one i'm
going to do because i normally would say
and i'm going to be careful here she's a
lot like kamala
until you see her she's all shiny and
the media paints her up but the minute
you really focus on her she's not
likeable she's not she's nasty she's
definitely you think she's nasty she's
the authoritarian in that family
all that matters is nc speech he gave
for biden i mean they painted over it
what a beautiful speech but just go back
and watch it
yourself and look at her mannerisms
notice by the way she'll never mention
kamala because she hates kamala harris
how funny would it be if they like the
only person they have is michelle
obama's like she's coming out you gotta
show it she walks out with a big old
smile and she's waving and then she goes
this country is a bunch of disgusting
deplorables
that's rush how do you know she hates
kamala harris
uh
just the vibe you get no she hates
kamala harris um and actually obama
doesn't like biden i mean these
relationships because obama is quoted as
saying never under underestimate joe
biden's ability to f things up she feels
like their uh her husband kind of made a
fool of her a little bit and then it he
he did this and i'm gonna walk the line
here but i'm gonna do it
there's like
rumors
and uh he made this public statement
about how she was the most attractive
attorney general in the country which
apparently michelle didn't like very
much oh i see then they're
generally
paradise separate vacations
and
drama
obama drama it's the obama is definitely
not no drama obama
he's got drama and uh you know he's he's
a cool cat in front of the camera you
know you got to give it to him uh but
his wife is not and i'm telling you when
that comes out on camera and
i know what happened the american people
i know exactly what happened
they're at a fundraiser
kamala's sitting there and she's
drinking obama walks up and they're
talking and he goes uh you know campbell
i blew up a bunch of kids when i was
president and she's like
how many kids did you blow up
she was like wow
wow she's like i also love torturing
people he was like we got something in
common
yeah kamala harris man when tulsi
gabbard roasted her on the dnc stage it
was one of the best moments in political
history it was and she's got a
reputation which michelle obama knew
about well before the rest of the
country did
and you know i mean it is
she's got a reputation oh yeah
is that a real is that oh
she basically that she slept away to the
top she did or well well that's the
rumor she selected willie brown's top
yeah she slept with people that she was
working with you know then got promoted
yes and got to and then got like
hand-picked by the guy who runs the
machine out there who was her boyfriend
30 years or elder i think right
something like that willie brown um
and sadly when she first got the top cop
job in that city he was a decent guy
uh but willie just wanted to put his
girl in there so they they destroyed
this guy and when she did she broke uh
fundraising laws and you know basically
had to pay a small fine because of her
relationship with william when he got
her out
it's it's bad you know i i think what
actually happened and i don't blame
obama for this you know kamala got real
close whispered in his ear tell me about
all the kids you blew up he was like oh
boy that was around that was it he
couldn't handle it he was just like well
there was one kid and then there's
another kid
all the military-aged males that we blew
up too michelle's like what are you on
the phone with her for three hours at
night
he's got a lot more about the kids so
there's a texting there was a thing
called the disposition matrix you're
familiar with it no it's uh it's the
disposition matrix is the formal name
for obama's kill list yes he was given
uh
it was called like baseball cards every
tuesday and he would select who to kill
yikes so he's he's he's in his you know
he's in his bed and he's sitting on a
stomach with kicking his feet and he's
like well we had the anwar unlucky bloom
uh he was american citizen no charger
trail uh and then i blooped his son and
then he starts listing all people just
down the list and camel's like oh say
more names who else did you blow up what
about julian assange locked him in a
prison
yeah you know that was all the
authoritarian wet dreams yeah that was
one of the worst stories of his
presidency
yeah i mean collateral you know whoops
uh collateral yeah it was me either but
that was those for those that don't
argue because yeah people should know
uh anwar al-awlaki was a jihadi he was
an american citizen and so uh we blew
him up that was it the drone strike
killed him without charge or trial wow
and uh
in somalia right i think it was in
somalia yeah yeah they or was it in
yemen it was in yemen
i think it was yemen yeah anwar was in
yemen i think oh i thought abdulrahman
was in yemen uh then i thought both were
right it might have been yeah so uh
anwar al-awlaki was an american citizen
who was killed by obama that's murder i
don't
know
yeah was killed in yemen for sure okay
yemen that's just murder you don't get
to vote it's a military operation
targeting an american citizen no we have
charge or trial you can't execute
somebody who's an american citizen let
alone i don't like the fact they do it
to anybody abdulrahman al-laki was a 16
year old american citizen who was
vacationing in yemen visiting his
grandparents blew up a civilian
restaurant with a drone strike and went
oops i don't buy it
my opinion is obama was telling
everybody
if you screw with us i will murder your
kids yeah that's what he did yeah when i
was intentional not fine i mean tim this
is a guy
who worked with the bush this is
somebody and i don't want to say work
with the bush administration but after 9
11 the bush state department was looking
around for influential imams to help
them reach out to the muslim community
amwal avalaki was one of
the invite you know he got invited to
that initial
you know dinner come come hang out let's
all get together figure out how to do
outreach he was an imam in virginia so
how did he get from
you know you're going to be our point
man
to the muslim american community in the
dc suburbs how did you go from that to
being public enemy number one what
happened in the time period
you know where bush cut him loose and
we're supposed to believe his kid died
in an accident
it's too it's i'll tell you this and
then no trunks
if anyone in this country accidentally
killed a 16 year old and uh a civilian
restaurant would they be in prison right
you betcha right not obama he cannot
kill him
he killed the son two weeks after he
killed the dad that's right blowing up a
civilian restaurant yeah they've been
accountable eating outside at a civilian
restaurant in yemen that's right and the
obama administration ordered a drone
strike blowing them up so technically
this position could you imagine if trump
did that they went nuts when he killed
hassan
trump had a commando raid that killed
abdulrahman's younger sister
so was there a legitimate target in that
though or there was a legitimate target
in in the claims of the abdulrahman
al-awlaki situation now the one thing i
will say is
i think all of it demands an
investigation
if trump ordered a commando raid and a
seven-year-old american girl was killed
i want to see absolutely however
with abdulrahman al-awlaki this is
definitive we have the reports we have
the official statements from the u.s
government they know they did it they
admit they did it with donald trump and
the seven-year-old uh sister of uh
abdulrahman we have
family testimony that this is actually
what happened so no real hard evidence
other than claims made by people who are
there either way i'd love to see an
inquiry i don't i don't think we should
sit back and allow the executive branch
to just be like we killed somebody we
were accused we ignore it i'm not saying
put trump on trial and scream and wave
your arms in the air i'm saying let's
get a real answer that's what that was
you mess up i'm also i'm also not going
to play this game where you know i say
oh okay well you know trump did it no no
obama was was the one who who killed
these people and i think it was four
american citizens then we can have we
could have a discussion about what
happened with trump in a commando raid
but i want to i want to start with obama
first and not lose track of things not
that i think anyone's anything will ever
happen
but justifying it's it's that's a
dangerous line justifying uh he was just
a terrorist you know he was al-qaeda's
main propaganda guy he uh he ran inspire
look at january 6th everything that's
going on you could be the domestic
terrorist tomorrow i could be the
domestic terrorist tomorrow and that was
just completely blown over
you know we all went on with our lives
and don't think that the u.s government
is beyond this stuff we've seen
we've seen what happened with um what
was it in uh in philadelphia what was it
the cops blew up that neighborhood
would you remember what that was called
i don't i don't but
you know there's plenty of examples of
these kent state
ruby ridge oh man that's right even wake
up i was just at waco too oh brutal
stuff thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm we'll see you all there
you